[Music]
step into the shopping center of the
future
a world filled with exciting ideas
since they started popping up in the
1950s
malls have been the quintessential
american shopping experience
bustling temples dedicated to the
wonders and excesses of retail
food service and entertainment the rise
of the mall coincided with the growth of
the suburbs
the heyday of the malls really is the
1970s
sometimes referred to as the mauling of
america
they really thrived at providing
some sort of public gathering space some
sort of social
life in addition to actually
giving people places to shop over the
past few decades before then
lots of developers were building malls
and it kind of coincided
with the growth of highways so as more
people started traveling
and interstate started being built
developers really wanted to put
something to attract people to stop
take a look at an average american mall
today however and you'll see a very
different picture
closed stores and empty hallways became
the norm in many malls even before kova
19 delivered them another set of
problems in 2020.
so what happened this is the story of
the rise and fall
of american malls
when malls work best they survived and
thrived
thanks to their anchor stores those are
the stores that are on the edges of the
malls
and that are outward facing to the
parking lot so if you're a shopper
you're going to walk through one of
these big usually a department store
so if you're thinking about macy's or
sears or jcpenney
those are called the anchor stores so
once shoppers are done shopping there
maybe they wander to the middle part of
the mall shopping at the other apparel
shops
or even going to buy some food but
you really have to have you know a
reason for people to shop in the first
place
because anchors bring in all those
people they tend to pay very little rent
around 80 of income for mall owners come
from the inline stores inside the mall
over the past few decades malls have
been facing challenges from all sides
the first being there's just too many of
them
as early as in the 90s the malls were
beginning
to compete with each other we have a lot
more
retail square footage per capita than
canada
we have almost seven times more retail
square footage per capita
than europe after the 2008 financial
crisis lowered retail spending across
the board
malls and especially their department
stores also had to contend with a new
challenge that was growing fast
malls started to suffer in the early
2000s with the rise of online shopping
suddenly they didn't have that captive
audience who
had to go to the mall to buy something
you didn't have to
get up get in your car drive all the way
to the mall and then see a bunch of
other people you can just do it from the
comfort of your home
department stores overall have become
less relevant over the years
many have fallen totally off and that's
sears jcpenney several bankruptcies in
this space
have have really hurt the industry but
as
department stores go so does the mall
oftentimes
so if department stores start closing
locations that means they're usually
leaving malls
this is the greenbrier mall in southwest
atlanta georgia
it's in many ways emblematic of the
problems facing malls today
it's been there since 1965 so for more
than half of a century
it's been serving this area of atlanta
that's predominantly black
and also its middle class neighborhood
it started with anchor stores that were
department stores so you had jcpenney
and then riches which was later bought
by macy's so you had these two
national chains it had the first
chick-fil-a
in a mall like that type of format so
when you think about the history of
malls like greenbriar had like the
perfect template
but now macy's um will be exiting the
mall
meaning that the mall will be left
without an anchor which is
vital to attracting other shoppers to
come into the stores
greenbrier then becomes kind of an
example or test for
all these other middling malls across
america
about what do you do when these large
department stores
as a business decision on their end are
trying to just stay in the high
quality malls how does a middling mall
survive what's their next strategy
[Music]
greenbriar is a textbook example of how
closely the deterioration of the middle
class in the u.s is tied to the health
of its malls
the median income for the surrounding
area has reduced by six thousand nine
hundred and five dollars over the past
15 years
to a total of twenty thousand seven
hundred and fifty six dollars per year
and yet residents and store owners hope
that greenbrier mall will see better
days
malls are made up of the people and
communities that help fuel them
greenbriar is still a place that people
go to and cherish
even if on paper it doesn't have the
elements that make it a thriving mall
a lot of the existing constituents and
residents there feel in many respects
that they worked hard their whole lives
you know to be able to experience the
american dream
the single-family suburban house in a
leafy
yard near a big mall that had
a a great macy's then you know
they're very reluctant to see
that taken away from them
now that macy's is gone greenbriar may
try to take inspiration from what many
malls were doing in the years following
the financial crisis
focusing not on shopping but experiences
that was a trend we were seeing
you know in 2016 up into the pandemic
pretty much
and by experiences i mean everything as
dramatic as a water park
or hosting like concerts to have people
want to come other than just to buy
stuff having
instagramable moments making sure your
store is pretty that people want to take
a photo
and post it on instagram or twitter
historically the mall has always been a
place for teenagers
you like to hang out see your friends
and also kind of be seen
at the mall and that hasn't completely
changed like before the pandemic
about 95 percent of gen z so today's
teenagers
had gone to a mall in a three-month
period so teenagers are still going to
the mall
and they've always been key to having
thriving malls
because they're coming into their
spending power and once you went over
teens hopefully you're really winning
over a loyal customer for life
but thanks to lockdowns across the
country most malls at one point or
another were shuttered in 2020
that means no one using the
multi-billion dollar american dream
mall's indoor ski slope
no one going to the king of prussia
mall's indoor skydiving attraction
basically the pandemic gave malls what
they didn't need
another problem what would your net
income or net operating income
have been in 2022 without covid and what
is it now
in a post-covered world so our view is
roughly
10 percent hit to net income over that
period
that's vince tabone from the analytics
firm green street advisors which rates
american models from a to d
just like a report card and if malls did
have a report card they wouldn't exactly
make
honor roll here in the u.s
out of the thousand malls in the country
there are roughly 250
malls we grade a minus or better
the b and c quality moles which is the
vast majority of the moles by
count we think are on a negative
trajectory
and it's going to depend on a lot of the
local dynamics ownership
decisions around how much money to
invest in the property will determine
whether this you know mall can survive
as retail
or it's a you know rapidly melting ice
cube
while there have been a few bankruptcies
among real estate investment trusts
that own mostly b to d malls in the past
few years
a malls really are doing just fine
some of the most productive shopping
centers in the country
are super high-end so i'm talking about
baal harbor shops down in miami florida
there's americana manhasset in long
island's gold coast
the grove in los angeles these are
places that have
all high-end stores and have done quite
well
a lot of that has to do with efficiency
of their property so their sales per
square foot are really high
but also they've invested a lot in their
actual
mall because it has to look beautiful it
has to have all the services that
that a wealthy shopper expects
so what will the future hold for less
sought after malls that can't revive
their golden years
[Music]
for many of these malls it will mean
closure and then hopefully
conversion if they can't get a new use
to come in it's expensive but you can
just demolish it
and there are still quite a lot of sites
just sitting
waiting amazon has been picking up more
and more of those
building their big fulfillment centers
also
a lot of communities think this is an
opportunity you know to
redevelop reinhabit this dead mall
to help that community meet the
challenges
it was never originally designed for the
number one
reuse of an existing mall is as
workspace it's actually pretty easy to
just throw some carpeting down
cut a few more windows and turn it into
office space
the sort of number two reuse of malls is
either
medical healthcare or education
lots of great examples of community
colleges
all the way down to elementary schools
moving into malls
and then the third strategy that i still
i wish happened
more is actually just demolishing them
all
and re-greening either
reconstructing the wetlands that used to
be there and that
frankly we never should have built on in
the first place or
providing community parks and gardens
while most analysts say post-pandemic
retail shopping could breathe some life
back into the american mall
many are not long for this world
depending on where you live it might be
time to make one last visit
grab some food do some shopping and say
farewell
[Music]
you